hey hey was geht nicht viel meine eltern
sind bereits mit allein zu haus und bei
dir
es sind ja ja und damit herzlich kommen
immer wieder leute ich habe an meiner
seite meinen bruder max leute denn es
wird zeit dass wir in dieser kombination
wieder mal auf einer der dümmsten
werbung auf youtube eingehen die rede
ist dabei von aso
ja wir haben es uns natürlich schon mal
zusammen angeschaut viele von euch
werden es gesehen haben und asa ist
wirklich einfach berühmt dafür komische
werbung zu machen und es gibt eine ganze
menge an neuen werbe clips von a wie wir
uns natürlich nicht entgehen lassen
können ich habe mit großer bestürzung
habe ich auch festgestellt dass auch
einige bekanntere deutsche youtuber und
instagram mach jetzt auf die dunkle
seite gewechselt sind und werbung für
user machen leute so nicht ganz wichtig
leute zieht euch auf jeden fall auch die
anderen videos reihen habe in der
beschreibung verlinkt und einfach leute
muss man der aktuellen sich dass man ja
sagen damit euch 100.000 mehr so eng
beisammen sitzen max wohnhalle zwei
häuser neben mir und wir sind de facto
ein haushalts und wir sehen uns jeden
tag und treffen uns jeden tag
wir leben in einem haushalt leben und
schützenzug nach außen
ok dann fangen wir an ganz sicher kann
sie den linken nicht ich habe da heißt
es
das licht und die erste fußball spielen
ein bisschen youtuber 73 k
und hat gerade mit flex rausgebracht
unbedingt abchecken regelt dann schauen
wir den film flags in diesem clip an
es wird noch ein schönes spät ist es hat
er gerade nach süße gesagt da süße gehen
wir zurück
hey ich hab da kein rgz du bist
verschlug aber das macht ja noch so spät
bekommen
es ist einfach 341 am mittag wie soll
die säulen die das jemals aus alten
tisch eigentlich muss ja schon längst
penh
was macht es so spät noch zu flexen
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlichkeit flex
aber daran arbeiten
da hast du noch ein schönes gesicht
sehen bevor ich auflegen er 41 zeit
offline zu gehen aber aber frage was
macht ihr hier
also bin ich jetzt noch was trocken
schönen abend ja gerne
das waren wirklich der trip flex muss
ich sagen in der tabelle also es ist zu
wenig wenn man also fünf sekunden so ja
ich würde mir macht's gut
es habe ich muss jetzt auch wieder
weitergespielt er wollte wirklich nur so
eine millisekunde hübsches gesicht sehen
und dann wollte sich aber auch endlich
verbissen ja der muss halt wirklich
einen schnitt von töpfen exzentrik der
club gerade eben hatte übrigens über
eine million aufrufe also wird über eine
million mal ausgespielt der hier auf 124
5 millionen ein toller spruch und schule
wir gespannt
haye hat wehgetan also vom himmel
gefallen ist weil es so aussieht als
wärst du schlecht gelandet
einfach mal so mobbing also hey so und
geht's dir gut
ja wieso also nicht so aussieht so
hässlich ist geht aber so hatte wollte
ja auch von einem komplett fremden
menschen geisteskrank beleidigt werden
könnte jetzt wieder wasser da ist
stocker stoppt bale zurück zum anfang
ganz einfach geil guck mal was gemerkt
den namen die haben einfach das gleiche
overlay benutzt beide typen heißen
harnisch also chemisch wird über diesen
hellmich
wenn sie so schlecht drauf das hat aber
auch einen charakter zufall oder das
wirklich beide typen heimlich heißt
natürlich jeder fassen jeder heißt
eigentlich sollte er sieht aus wie helm
ist ein helm ist ja egal das ist auch
nicht ohne
das ist einfach irgendwann einfach den
weg das ist einfach so ein typ so
vielleicht so afrikanischer abstammung
ein bisschen dunkler
er hat mir seine asiatischen haut und
kommen die auch gleich viel likes 284
hat helms zweiter klar aber ist dass das
ist auch nicht gerne schicke das ist
nicht das war der zweite es gibt einen
dritten über 1,38 millionen mal wurde
das läuten reingedrückt sei vorsichtig
was du dir wünschst in einem fitness
studio gedreht
sie hat gesagt das war genauso diese
stimme von aber sie so ich hätte so
gerne vor einem greenscreen zu stehen
und so mit irgendeiner person herum
schmal ist ob sie per sms 11 wenn die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass es hämisch ist
ist relativ nah ist kanada grund auch
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass er 284
leichter
ok überwachungsstaat schwimmbad schickt
auch so ein push benachrichtigung
liebst du deine familie etwas zu
kritisieren so achtung du solltest die
tür schließlich hat der vor der tür
steht
jeder kann wenn dein handy einfach denn
hier macht der und dann wieder
überwachungsstaat iphone 12 12 kann so
rundherum leuchten die haben das schon
bekommen egal
daher gibt dann geht aus ganze budget
wie wär's damit uns beiden also teil hab
ich mir jetzt nicht gewünscht ist also
nur ein euro job ja wie java sei sehr
vorsichtig was du dir wünschst ich habe
mir aber nicht gewünscht
ich habe mir keinen enddreißiger vor
einem greenscreen gewünscht achten wie
viel akzente
die haben häufig falsch geschehen ist
die gleiche grafik
ich nehme im wasser aber ein stilles 1
dass keine probleme bereitet ok wack ihr
ist es aber ein serienmörder einfach
mehr kranker vergewaltiger
du sagst so serien würde ich das schon
okay ihre frage weiter also ich frage
mich wurde er seine 284 leichen also
drauf ist 280 opfer danach umgebracht
hat als die jungs haben ein
wunderschönes spiel gemacht
ja diesen komplett auf crack sei aber da
da haben sie schon mal ein bisschen geld
ausgegeben bei green screen und studio
ausleuchten und sonst wäre ja und dann
holen die sich sowohl mario klein
es wird ja gerne jogi löw wichtig wie
vielleicht hat daniels schnell wir
müssen es herausfinden wir müssen es
investieren die haben es leider in 131
peer opel an
der ist wirklich nicht zu erkennen ist
overlay auch wo man einfach nicht
erkenne ich erkenne da 204 sagen wir mal
sagt man darf also jeder darf sich bei
sah anmelden vorausgesetzt er kommt aus
berlin da 284 likes ja sonst geht das
nicht denkt glaubt man nicht dass ihr
aus heidelberg mit 300 likes darein
keine vergessenheit als ehrlicher licht
kleine besser nächster club deutscher
tanzbär oder armut 184 like was sollte
das gucken wir uns nicht an
aber ich mag dessen bug ist ein fehler
ich glaube diese sollte die 1 oder 2
sein kommt aus berlin ja da dachte ich
sie ja okay wir uns jetzt erstmal die
erste zahl ende der typ kann ich
übrigens auch nicht rang zurück
also der muss mich eigentlich schon fast
weigern muss das sozusagen sicher dass
dort das neutor er hat die somit zehn
gezeugt er hat einfach so einen
schlaganfall da drüben und sie sagte er
du kannst du gut bewegen
die porträts er wirklich nicht getan ok
schiller hatten der pi lettischen
anfeuerung das wird ganz ganz schön das
respektvoll von dir an dieser stelle
noch rassistisch
was machen wenn ich das hier mache aus
dem bild verschwunden
papa kommen jetzt noch wasser du trittst
in seltsame situation mit serienmördern
von green screens es kann sein dass du
deine eigenen eltern in wirklich
peinliche situation der wechsel gedacht
nur aus berlin sein wer du hast wie du
hast eine andere zahl als 284 bei deinen
likes du [ __ ] okay sonst gibt es
ärger
sie hat einfach
also da natürlich vergisst einfach das
ganze mit dem einbruch hat sondern bin
gehe ich einfach wieder
ich hätte so eine medien die wir dann
eben besser zu machen
man nimmt also man die flugzeuge in die
twin 1000 dann kommt so dass ein
hersteller rückwärts wieder werden heute
wieder einiges gesehen hat hier drüben
ein für euch vorgeschlagen spd ablehnen
könnte meinen kann abonniert haben und
max abonnieren es war bereichernd es war
schön es war toll ich kann ja schon mal
sagen nur bleibt die leute bleibt trip
flex beginnt in zwei tagen wieder
macht's gut dass das mal rein in den vip
weg